These are the least diverse water group universities.
Now this is measured by
the percentage of attendance by ethnic minorities.
At No. 10 you have university of Sheffield at 22%
and No. 9 you have university of Leeds at 21.9%
and No. 8 we have university of Bristol at 20.1%,
at No. 7 we have Cardiff University at 19%,
at number six we have university of Liverpool at 16.4%,
at No. 5 at university of York at 15.7%,
at No. 4 we have Durham University at 13.7%,
at number three
at Newcastle University at 13.5%,
at number two
at university of Exeter at 10.6%
and the least diverse Russell Group
university will be Queen's University Belfast
with the percentage of ethnic minorities being 4.3%.